seit über 100 jahren gibt es sie die
antifa in der bundesrepublik war sie
zunächst friedlich später dann militant
doch wer ist sie wirklich nun gibt es
ein buch das dies klären will der
münchner historiker richard rohrmoser
hat es geschrieben und sagt er wolle die
antifa and dämonisieren
die friedensbewegung die
anti-akw-bewegung die frauenbewegung
diese bewegungen denke ich sind heute
alle ziemlich respektiert weil man ihnen
attestiert dass sie viel dazu
beigetragen haben für tempo richtung und
intensität des sozialen wandels
und meines erachtens hat die
antifaschistische bewegung dasselbe
geleistet der berliner künstler bernd
langer ist seit über 40 jahren
antifaschist schon als schüler
organisierte er demonstrationen gegen
nazis der motorwagen grunde genommen
dass man gegen diese ja verstaubte alten
strukturen angegangen ist neu an einer
zeit wo alte nazis in amt und irgendwann
anfang der 80er jahre in seiner heimat
bad lauterberg bernd langer und seine
antifa demonstrieren gegen ein kolonial
denkmal vor dem sich bis dahin
regelmäßig traditionsverbände treffen
und die stadt die sogar willkommen heißt
ganz ganz frappierend wie viele
veranstaltungen von ss veteranen
verbände in den 1980 er und 90 er jahren
noch stattgefunden haben und wie viele
solche gruppen existiert haben sich
regelmäßig getroffen haben und dass
weder der staat noch die
zivilbevölkerung dem substanzielles
entgegen gesetzt hat
83 blockiert die antifa einen parteitag
der npd die gewerkschaften wollten
lieber auswärts demonstrieren es kommt
zur straßenschlacht so auch zwei jahre
später in frankfurt am main wieder gegen
die npd dabei wird der 36 jährige günter
sache von einem wasserwerfer überrollt
er stirbt
das war schon so ein weckruf auch
international an antifaschistinnen es
gab dann in vielen größeren städten
europaweit demonstrationen die
geburtsstunde der sogenannten autonomen
antifa die sieht nun nicht allein im
nazis sondern auch in der polizei und
den capital ihre gegner fast 14 tage
lang remis in der bundesrepublik habe
überall demonstration
banken und polizei waren und alles
gelernt langer erfindet damals das logo
der bewegung die original fahne maske
und helm oben auf dem regal
fortan marschiert die autonome antifa
ganz in schwarz maskiert behelmt und
unter langers fahnen
das ist ein beutestück aus den
90er jahren anfang der neunziger es
damals um skinhead mal abgenommen wurden
rohrmoser das buch beschreibt wie
entschieden die antifa gegen neonazis
vorgeht ein seismograph
antidemokratische tendenzen sei die
bewegung
die antifaschistische bewegung hat das
aus einem defizit seitens der
staatlichen behörden institutionen
geleistet also eigentlich eher eine
reaktion denn eine aktion
als reaktion auf die pogrome von rostock
und hoyerswerda auf neonazistische
mordanschläge entdeckt nun auch der
staat den antifaschismus für sich und
gibt bis heute hunderte von millionen
aus es entstanden dann sehr viele
staatlich geförderte
initiativen inzwischen vor allem in den
1990 und 2000 jahren ist es ja ein stück
weit auch zur staatsräson geworden
saskia esken bekennt antifa zu sein
selbstverständlich aufregung als
herauskommt dass die bundes
innenministerin für ein antifa blatt
einen artikel geschrieben hat im
bundestag ist es martina renner
abgeordnete der linken die mit dem logo
der antifa für unmut sagt
der antifa ich hatte dafür ein
ordnungsruf in stuttgart begegnen ihm
gut tut und andreas ziegler vor zwei
jahren der antifa sie gehören zur afg
nahm gewerkschaft zentrum automobil
gelaufen mai 2020 schwarz gekleidete und
vermummte antifa überfallen die rechten
gewerkschafter die sind auf dem weg zu
einer querdenker demo und legen
plötzlich auf der straße
die ersten zwei hinweg dann kamen die
nächsten zwei dann kamen die nächsten 2
und jeder hat einmal immer drauf
geschlagen sie haben vier flasche auf
dem kopf zertrümmert er hat darum geht
es praktisch hier da habe ich ein buch
das ist auch vom 5 5 aus und dann hier
ein haarriss andreas ziegler liegt
wochenlangen koma ein anderer ist auf
einem auge beinahe blind sogenannte
militante antifaschistinnen bekennen
sich im internet zum überfall schmerz
stress und sachschaden seien legitime
politische mitte zwei der täter werden
zu mehrjährigen haftstrafen verurteilt
ich denke die antifaschistische bewegung
wäre deutlich respektierter wenn sie
sich öfter klarer von diesen
gewaltaktionen distanzieren würde auch
bestimmte endlos initiativen und gruppen
die mit ihnen im zusammenhang stehen
berlin vor gut drei wochen es ist der
tag der entscheidung über eine
impfpflicht
auf der einen seite des brandenburger
tors stehen die impfgegner auf der
anderen die antifa
von anbeginn der impf proteste ist die
antifa mit dabei und es geht ihr nicht
nur um rechte die bei den demos
mitlaufen
die antifaschistischen gruppen
übernehmen diesbezüglich auch eine
korrektiv funktion weil ihrer meinung
nach von staatlicher seite zu wenig
überzeugungskraft geleistet wird dass
sich die leute impfen lassen sollen die
antifa seite an seite mit dem staat auch
bei den impfgegnern gibt das linke sogar
welche mit schwarz roter fahne
[Musik]
bernd lange kann das im engagement
vieler antifa gruppen nicht verstehen
auch nicht die rohe gewalt gegen
einzelpersonen wenngleich es auch antifa
ganz ohne militanz nicht geben können
neonazis wird er sich weiterhin
entschieden entgegenstellen richard
rohrmoser tourt derzeit mit seinem buch
auch bei der antifa doch immer wenn er
zur kritik an der gewalt kommt gibt es
berufe zu offenen diskussionen sei dann
aber kaum einer bereit doch genau die
brauche es